antiguos aliados convertidos en rivales
políticos después de una magnífica
relación con Donald Trump ron de santis
Mike pence y Chris kristy decidieron ir
en contra de su antiguo líder y forjar
su propio camino político a pesar de
transitar en bandos Opuestos los
aspirantes tienen en común varios
aspectos militan en el mismo partido el
republicano quieren llegar a la casa
blanca y necesitan derrotar a Trump el
último en cargar contra la principal
figura republicana fue su antigua mano
derecha en la dirección del país
creo que cualquiera que se ponga por
encima de la Constitución nunca Debería
ser presidente de Estados Unidos y
cualquiera que le pida a otra persona
que lo ponga por encima de la
Constitución nunca debería volver a ser
presidente de Estados Unidos
por su parte de santis tuvo palabras más
duras contra Trump
el liderazgo no se trata de
entretenimiento no consiste en el
señalamiento de virtudes no consiste en
una especie de espectáculo la esencia de
Liderazgo es producir resultados
sin embargo un aspecto no pasa por alto
la campaña de los principales candidatos
a republicanos gira en torno a Donald
Trump algo que puede resultar o no en su
beneficio
es emocionante hay muchas cosas por ahí
Creo que muchos republicanos mucha gente
está un poco desanimada porque Trump es
el favorito seguro que será emocionante
para el partido republicano este año
el gobernador de la Florida ron de
santis es el candidato con más
posibilidades de discutir la nominación
republicana contra Trump una opción que
el ex mandatario hizo ver mucho antes de
que de Santi se decidiera con un ataque
a su Estilo se refería a the santis como
ron de santimonios algo así como ron el
santurrón